hey uh a couple months ago i interviewed
this trump-endorsed republican house
candidate j.r majewski we spoke about a
lot of things with j.r majewski in some
areas he was quite radical and others he
was not quite so radical but we have now
learned that j.r majewski has completely
fabricated his supposed record as a
military veteran who served in
afghanistan
multiple times this is stolen valor
folks
multiple times j.r majewski has said i
did serve in afghanistan it turns out
that he didn't
this was if i understand correctly
broken by the associated press
in which brian sladisko and james
laporta wrote
j.r majewski presents himself as an air
force air force combat veteran deployed
to afghanistan after 9 11 once
describing tough conditions including a
lack of running water forcing him to go
more than 40 days without a shower
military documents obtained by the ap
tell a different story majewski never
deployed to afghanistan he did six
months loading planes at an air base in
qatar
that's an ally
it was very safe from any fighting
majewski's account of his time in the
military is only one aspect of his bio
that's suspect his post-military career
has been defined by exaggerations
conspiracy theories talk of violent
action against the u.s government and
occasional financial duress
thanks to an unflinching allegiance to
trump he also stands a chance of
defeating the long-time democratic
congresswoman marcy captor now listen
this guy is out of his mind and we knew
that from the interview i did with him
he has no business being a member of the
house
i hope
that these lies yes this is stolen valor
i hope that these lies about his
military service
end up torpedoing his campaign he should
he should just drop out he probably
won't let's take a look at some clips
here is j.r majewski claiming that he
did a tour of duty in afghanistan but he
doesn't really like to talk about it
what a humble guy huh did you serve in
afghanistan yes he did
did you serve in afghanistan yes i did
that is a lie
that is a lie
okay i'm just gonna play it once more so
that there's no ambiguity here about
whether he lied
did you serve in afghanistan yes i did
how many tours
one
what what year were you there what years
uh 2000
2002 2003
wow so you served right right at the
beginning yeah was that experience like
um
tough
tough i don't like talking about my milk
it was really tough when he was in
afghanistan never happened just a lie
sorry
experience not not that um
not that we've said too much i just
don't i don't really like to
i really don't like to divulge a lot of
things about the military because you
know they're to me
you know it was a
it was a tough time in life
um
you know the military wasn't easy but
in retrospect it's one of the best
decisions i've ever made
it's a lie folks
he loaded planes in qatar for six months
that's what he did there was no tough
experience in afghanistan now as far as
his claim that he didn't shower for 40
days
maybe that's true but it certainly
wasn't because there was no running
water here's another example of this
wherein he says that he
uh he he it's something it's it's a
really detailed story about playing
video games in afghanistan
he was never in afghanistan it's just a
lie xbox and i'd be on that thing till
like midnight just
talking and shooting people man it was
fun
but i also remember now that i'm
thinking about that um
but yeah we played the division man for
forever and then the division two game
came out and we just kind of got
we just you know we played it for like a
month or two and it wasn't the same so
we we quit but
um
i remember being in the desert man
writing in afghanistan and uh that is a
lie
he was not in afghanistan
um
somebody's mom sent
um a playstation 2 or something like
that over with grand theft auto
and
anyway you get the point so the point is
he was playing video games when he was
in afghanistan and then there's a whole
bunch of these a whole bunch of these
examples of him uh just lying here's
another one
did she serve in the military no she uh
and you did you you were air force okay
you served in operation enduring freedom
correct
absolutely afghanistan yes sir
yes sir
in afghanistan it's just another lie and
i could even find uh find find more of
these um and they are quite despicable
in fact just to be thorough
there was one more here
uh yeah here he actually he says he lost
his grandmother when he was in
afghanistan i have no regrets with my
life one or two and um those those
regrets are you know if i could do them
over
um it would be things that i didn't know
i could have controlled
you know yeah but the only you know the
most important thing that's ever
happened probably is i lost my
grandmother when i was in afghanistan
and i didn't i didn't get to see her
that that he wasn't in afghanistan now
did he lose his grandmother while he was
in qatar maybe but that's a totally
different story that's not combat
so by the standards of republicans
this guy should be forced to drop out
not a single republican should be voting
for this guy republicans claim that we
should revere our veterans now of course
they don't do it we don't even provide
good medical care in many cases to our
veterans although the va does the best
it can
we really leave behind veterans in many
ways when it comes to jobs as well but
forget about the fact that they don't
really mean it
stolen valor
should be the end of the road for these
republicans and yet j.r majewski might
still win his race horrible stuff and
really good reporting by the ap and
others
figuring out that this guy apparently
made up the entire thing let me know
what you think find me on twitter at
deepakman
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below